[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
good morning last
night phil hogan submitted his
resignation
from the post as trade commissioner
i respect this i am
very grateful to phil hogan for his
tireless and successful work
as a commissioner and as a member of the
college
and i thank him warmly
for his valuable contribution to the
work of the commission
not only in this mandate but also in the
previous mandate
where he was in uh commissioner in
charge
of agriculture and rural development
over the past days i discussed with phil
hogan
about his movements in ireland in light
of information that
emerged regarding respect of public
health guidelines
in ireland in the current circumstances
as europe fights to reduce the spread of
the corona virus
and europeans make sacrifices
and accept painful restrictions
i expect the members of the college
to be particularly vigilant
about compliance with applicable
national
or regional rules or recommendations
in accordance with article 246 of the
treaty
it is up now to the irish government to
present
suitable candidates for commissioner of
irish nationality as in the past
i will invite the irish government to
propose
a woman and a man
executive vice president wildest donkeys
will assume
at interim responsibilities for trade
matters
and at a later stage i will decide on
the final allocation of portfolios
in the college of commissioners thank
you
you